basil paste it feels really good it the
best basil you've ever eaten
Govan green CEO Viraj poori knows his
basil lettuce and tomatoes he also knows
New York City has plenty of space to
grow them not on the ground but on Route
one vastly underutilized resource we do
have is unused rooftop space we've hard
to look up on the rooftops there
certainly was some trepidation on the
parts of some building owners but a lot
of them also thought it was a pretty
compelling idea the idea now a reality
is building commercial scale pesticide
free greenhouses on roofs this 20,000
square foot rooftop farm grows food
hydroponically 365 days a year
thanks to proprietary technology we have
a weather station outside that has
temperature humidity co2 wind direction
wind speeds solar radiation if it gets
too hot or too cold
fans heater shades and vents kick in to
keep conditions at an ideal 65 to 75
degrees a controlled environment capable
of getting food to consumers faster and
fresher than a conventional farm if I
pick it today how quickly does it get on
the shelves oftentimes product that you
will find in the supermarket will be
harvested that same day the company
built its second greenhouse on the roof
of Brooklyn's first Whole Foods Market
one of its more than 50 retail customers
across New York we're growing bok choy
green leaf lettuce red leaf lettuce
arugula Gotham greens raised 15 million
dollars from investors to get its
business off the ground so far it's
reaping impressive returns and you're
profitable today since day one
essentially we've been profitable this
year we'll probably do over a hundred
percent growth in revenue and next year
probably about three hundred percent
forecasted this farm will probably yield
almost twenty times the yield per unit
area compared to a conventional farm
yields more but pori says it probably
costs a lot more than conventional
farming we're not trying to say this is
the best way to do it whether this is
the future of farming does it have a
role to play absolutely we're disrupting
the conventional supply chain we're
growing extremely high quality products
in close proximity to large urban market
it's definitely entrepreneurial events
or but at the same time at the heart of
it we are farmers were urban farmers